how some gum rows just can't see if I'm
recording or not welcome to my name is
Pierre ba welcome to you have to
fertilize the eggs I don't know if you
couldn't read that or not click this
game has one sole purpose to fertilize
the egg
click the start experience the struggle
for birth gravity in tertia I don't know
what that is
physics is like a round-robin the unborn
child is like a real number
it cannot be to be divided by zero
think about that you you better think
about that girl left and right arrow
keys to see address up to threaten
average oh you know ah all right
the controls are not really oh there we
go vagina swim and not very doing very
well swimming around another dog
I'm swimming around in a vagina I try to
make your brain says that's right I'm in
a vagina I'm swimming it around and over
swimming around enough
I try to make a princess alright I don't
think I have a fair chance of actually
catching up on those probably try this
again round come on buddies yes yes back
off [ __ ] this is my vagina this is my
hometown
oh oh oh you think it tough huh push me
yes how'd it oh oh oh you press up Go Go
Superman vagina powers come on sperm
come on sperm you can out now now come
on sperm come on sperm
come on sperm you can do it I'm proud of
you sperm I like that hat - come on
sperm come on sperm don't let give me
now now come on you can do it yes come
on sperm yes now now I have to fertilize
the egg I have a hat [ __ ] y'all
come on you can do it yes yes yes God
God no that's too much else that's too
much up stop it come on
this is difficult holy [ __ ] why did I
make this the last night yeah get that
joke come on come on I think I'm pretty
[ __ ] close move it my vagina
Mariano now now now close the princess
firstborn you won the game but did you
actually win what about the others
don't all right that was pretty [ __ ]
weird game I just wanted to play
something extra for so Simon just made
the montage and I spend a lot of time on
it anyway hope you enjoyed like a fairy
she did so practical my bro today I'll
leave a download link for this game in
the description if you're interested and
that's pretty much it
[Music]